the big splash today came from a team
that rarely makes big splashes what it's
been twice in the past 20 years where
there's been a big money expenditure by
the patriots one of them came after the
market got going with stefan gilmore
they paid market value adelius thomas if
you remember that shireen in 2007 is
another one but today it was boom bang
pow from john ooh smith
the tight end from the titans matthew
judon the pass rusher from the baltimore
ravens jalen mills gets signed by the
patriots a defensive back on a four-year
deal and davon godshall the
dolphins defensive tackle all joined the
patriots all today now remember none of
these deals are official until after
wednesday at 4 pm eastern but i've never
seen the patriots spend this kind of
money in that period of time
no me either mike it was a 140 last
check they may have signed somebody by
now but last check 146 million dollars
spent today 81.2
million guaranteed that is more than we
see the patriots usually spend in free
agency
i think this means mike that they think
they need some additions and they're
close right they've resigned cam newton
think he'll be better in the offense
they're getting those players back who
opted out aside from marcus cannon who
they who they've since traded but i
think bill belichick thinks he's
building a team here mike that can
contend for the division title uh going
forward after these moves but we know
free agency's not the way you build a
team right it's through the draft so you
still need to draft well and get those
young players to to play valuable snaps
for you if not make make valuable starts
for you mike well and that's exactly the
message i take away from this this is a
team that was frustrated by what
happened last year and even though a lot
of people look at the patriots and they
have an attitude as if new england
bottomed out at 3 and 13 or something
like that they were still seven and nine
they were still very much alive going
into the mid to late part of december
and
there aren't many games you could point
to and say well if that one had gone
differently that would have gone
differently their playoff team you take
away the cam newton coveted 19 bout that
he had that kind of screwed everything
up they had the chiefs on the ropes
early in the season the game that cam
newton missed this is a team that is not
far away and whether it was intentional
or coincidental
they managed to compile a ton of cap
space tom curran was on with us on
friday he suggested it just was
serendipitous
i still think at some point even though
it may have started by happenstance it
became a happening for the patriots and
they decided we're going to embrace this
we're going to live this we're going to
run with this and next year
we're going to be in a position to spend
when others can't i'm still surprised
though
that they went all in so quickly i
thought the approach would be
wait
and let the market soften and go out and
bargain shop maybe they'll do both but
they make those big splashes right out
of the gates with jude on godzilla mills
and smith and they're going to be better
they're instantly going to be better
now we know that
few teams go out and buy a championship
in free agency but when you consider the
unique dynamics of this season and where
the patriots currently are
that this is this is what they're doing
to improve the team oh and they have a
date with tom brady at some point this
year
don't think that's not part of this they
have to get the house in order before
the prodigal son returns home and they
don't want to slay the fatted calf they
want to slay him and they need a better
team than what they had last year to do
it and i i doubt that they're done they
may be done in this first wave but
they're going to keep spending and
they're going to keep trying because
they ultimately shereen want to beat tom
brady
yeah and mike they still need moves at
receiver right we know they didn't have
that many weapons they now have gotten a
tight end who they think is going to be
really good in this offense but they
need receivers and that maybe has been
the biggest surprise to me today in free
agency and maybe it's because there's so
many of them out there but we haven't
seen right mike a big time big name
receiver go in free agency yet they're
all still out there so i'm not going to
put it past the patriots to sign one or
two of these receivers who are out there
well and the problem continues to be
what value can you fairly put on a kenny
gallaudet who didn't play much last year
and you can write it off to
he wasn't happy with his
contractual situation he wasn't happy
with the offers he was getting from the
lions so he wasn't going to push it if
he had a hamstring issue and he was
going to keep himself healthy and ready
for the market and with juju smith
schuster i keep coming back to the fact
that he's not a number one receiver i
see these huge numbers get thrown around
for juju but
you got to have a number one you can't
make him number one so if you have a
number one who's already under a veteran
contract it's going to be glaring if you
pay smith schuster 12 15 million dollars
per year whatever it is that it's going
to be in the final number the only way
that it makes sense is for a team that
has a number one
firmly established under a rookie
contract and can't be paid a second
contract yet
then it's not glaring it's still glaring
but there's nothing anybody can do about
it and that may be why the raiders are
in the mix i know miles disagrees with
me on whether or not henry rugs is a
number one but you treat him as a number
one because he's got the speed to draw
double coverage and he's got the
potential to become a guy that truly is
your number one wide out and then juju
is is your number two so i think that's
the practical challenge and look if if
i'm the patriots i i don't know that
that i trust my evaluation of any
receivers i think given their history
i'm tempted to do the george costanza
pick the opposite path of whatever it is
bill belichick thinks is the right way
to go because we've seen time and again
they've they've not done well when it
comes to receivers especially young ones
veterans yes young ones they they just
don't evaluate them well so free agency
would be the way to do it if there's
guys they like but i think that may be
the area sharing where they let the
market soften and then make moves at
guys who are left over and willing to do
one-year deals
and you know a guy who might fit them
perfectly is the guy who played with cam
newton who i think is unsung probably in
this pre-agent class and that's curtis
samuel for what he brought to that
panthers offense people don't talk about
him a lot but i mean he can run the ball
he can obviously catch passes that's
what he does best but he worked well
with cam so i think he's a guy that that
maybe you're right maybe the market sets
a little bit and then maybe he's a guy
that a team like the patriots could go
after and get who i think could be
really good now i don't know that he's
the number one receiver but i think he
could be good in your mixed core group
of receivers
yeah i i
i suspect they'll do more
i doubt that they'll do more now but
watch i'm
constantly checking twitter
messages we share and other text
messages i'm getting to see what's next
but
they've done plenty they've done plenty
and they've burned up a nice chunk of
that cap space they had available but i
think they will eventually be doing more
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports